qu'est devenu sabine dardenne une
adolescente de 13 ans qui a disparu le
28 mai dernier vers 7h30 le matin alors
qu'elle rejoignait à vélo son collège de
quint les recherches effectuées n'ont
rien donné les pompiers ont même sondé
l'escaut entre qu'un epec sans succès
c'est donc la thèse de l'enlèvement qui
a été retenu
le 18 juillet dernier la police
judiciaire de tournai a diffusé le
portrait robot d'un homme d'une
trentaine d'années type européen cheveux
châtains montrant un front légèrement
dégarni près de 25 mille affiches ont
été apposées dans des lieux publics de
belgique et du nord de la france
alors bien sûr des coups de téléphone
parviennent aux enquêteurs sabine a été
vu en belgique en espagne dans la région
lilloise dans les bouches du rhône
aucune piste sérieuse la gendarmerie de
tournée reste donc elle aussi dans
l'expectative
même le vtt de couleur verte de sabine a
pu être retrouvé ce qui laisse penser à
un enlèvement organisé une affaire qu'on
ne peut s'empêcher de rapprocher des
disparition de julie et mélissa 9 ans
aujourd'hui qui se sont évanouis en
plein après midi le samedi 24 juin 1995
dans leur quartier à hauteur de grâce
hollogne près de liège ce jour là elle
devait se promener pendant une
demi-heure est rentrée chez elle vers
17h30 on ne les reverra jamais en
belgique l'association marc et corinne
s'est constitué autour des familles
d'enfants disparus 30 bénévoles assurent
une permanence téléphonique
cette association a déjà reçu dans
d'autres affaires des témoignages
importants et même une fois le nom d'à
ravisseurs mais pour julie melissa et
sabine les espoirs s'amenuisent bonsoir
les terribles aveux de marc dutroux en
belgique un put inculpé d'enlèvement et
de séquestration d'enfant il a avoué ce
soir être l'auteur de plusieurs meurtres
d'enfants ainsi la gendarmerie a pu
découvrir à son domicile
trois cadavres bien didier trois
cadavres ont été retrouvés en début de
soirée dans la maison de sarcelles
bissière la gendarmerie fouillé les
lieux depuis hier soir deux des
dépouilles semble correspondre à deux
fillettes disparues l'été dernier le
troisième cadavre serait celui d'un
complice de marc dutroux aurait supprimé
dans un climat pesant tournant au climat
de lynchage marc dutroux est revenu cet
après midi à sars la buissière pour
indiquer aux enquêteurs l'emplacement
des corps la belgique découvre l'horreur
d'une affaire qui ne cesse de rebondir
depuis que l'on a retrouvés jeudi
vivantes laetitia sabine deux
adolescentes séquestré par du trou dans
une autre de ces maisons quatre autres
personnes dont les poudres de dutroux
sont entendus dans le cadre de la sphère
et l'on reparle de ces six autres
fillettes ou adolescente disparue en
belgique depuis 89
on est par exemple son nouvel d'année
cieux depuis l'été dernier à proximité
du lieu de leur disparition
les enquêteurs avaient relevé des
empreintes de pneus comparable à celle
de la cx de dutroux du matériel
pornographique retrouvé au domicile du
présumé meurtrier lancerait même la
piste d'un réseau international de
pédophilie
le procureur de liège en personne a
annoncé ce soir aux parents la mort des
deux fillettes retrouvées à sars la
buissière réaction d'un des pères cette
affichette apposée sur sa porte qui
interpelle un ministre de la justice
dutroux avait été condamnée en 86 pour
attentat à la pudeur
la belgique est sous le choc après les
aveux de marc dutroux et de ses
complices les corps de fillette de 8 ans
ont été retrouvés à hier soir dans le
jardin d'une de ses maisons près de
charleroi il également avoué
l'enlèvement l'été dernier de deux
adolescentes que l'on espère encore
vivante mais les enquêteurs belges
poursuivent leurs recherches et leurs
fouilles bertrand cocq cet après-midi
les pelleteuses de la gendarmerie sont à
nouveau entrés en action et la belgique
retient son souffle
ces nouvelles recherches se déroulent au
sud de charleroi dans une ville la
propriété d'un ami de marc dutroux
elles font suite aux tout derniers aveux
du pédophile à savoir l'enlèvement l'été
dernier à ostende de deux jeunes filles
anne et et fieux depuis mardi dernier et
l'arrestation de cet homme de 39 ans de
sa femme et de son complice le lièvre
les belges sont passés du soulagement à
l'horreur absolue
dans un premier temps du tour reconnaît
détenir deux adolescentes
sabine et laetitia chez lui dans une
cache qu'il révèle aux policiers les
fillettes sont vivantes et immédiatement
rendus à leurs familles
toutes les deux ont été abusés
sexuellement et lætitia la plus grande
dont l'enlèvement le 9 août dernier
avait déclenché l enquête policière ait
abouti à l'arrestation de dutroux n'a
passé que six jours derrière ces murs
mais sabine la plus petite
ils étaient séquestrés depuis deux mois
et demi c'est ce que faisait que je vais
éclater je ne sais plus ce que je fais
je voudrais jamais ma famille et tout ça
quand je lui disais ces mots mais des
fois j'ai pensé pas non plus mais
dutroux a fait pire interrogé sans
relâche l'homme craque une deuxième fois
il mène les enquêteurs dans son jardin
et là sous trois mètres de terre les
policiers ont trouvé trois corps les
restes de julie et mélissa deux petite
fille de 8 ans disparue depuis juin 1995
le troisième cadavre est celui d'un
homme un complice que dutroux avoue
avoir tué et qu'il accuse de la mort des
fillettes
julie et mélissa seraient mortes de faim
oublié dans une cave
tandis qu'il était en prison faut savoir
que le 6 décembre 1995 dutroux a été
arrêté à la suite d'un une affaire de
règlement de compte avec d'autres
complices dans une histoire de vol
qualifié à ce moment-là de trou aurait
chargé le lièvre de s'occuper des
gamines
quand il est sorti de prison le lierre
nous ce n'était pas occupé les gamines
était mourante et voilà
ce soir au terme de trois jours
d'insoutenables révélation la belgique
réclame justice
l'homme montrait du doigt c'est l'ancien
ministre de la justice justement aux
yeux de l'opinion publique il est
responsable d'avoir autorisé la
libération conditionnelle du violeur
marc dutroux en 1992 au funérarium un
interminable défilé toute la belgique
est venu encore aujourd'hui se
recueillir devant les cercueils de julie
et mélissa avant l'enterrement prévu
pour jeudi prochain et à 10h dans tout
le pays les sirènes ont retenti les
pompiers voulant eux aussi affiché au
grand jour leur tristesse et leur colère
à neufchâteau houle enquête vient d'être
centralisée le dossier est maintenant
entre les mains d'un seul homme le
procureur michel bourlet parmi les
inculpés
jean michel nihoul intéresse beaucoup le
procureur son mandat d'arrêt est
prolongée d'un mois
il reste donc en prison connu de la
justice il a été le patron d'un club
échangiste et pourrait être l'homme fort
du réseau de prostitution
le point de vue de monsieur denis houle
est toujours le même à savoir qu'ils y
clame haut et fort son innocence
je vous laisse donc imaginer dans ces
conditions ce que c'est quand on se dit
innocent d'être traîné dans la boue due
au nord de la belgique
non pour ce genre de chefs d'inculpation
on n'est pas dans un dossier de vol ou
de vol de voiture de choses de ce genre
c'est quelque chose d'odieux ce sont des
faits gravissimes
donc lorsqu'on clame son innocence et
bien ça devient très vite un enfer dans
ce pays' marc dutroux et son complice
michel lelièvre auraient été les hommes
de main de jean michel nihoul chargé de
kidnapper les adolescentes et de les
cacher dans ses nombreuses maisons
aménageant les cavs en prison hier la
police a arrêté un autre suspect
hollande et caspar filler déjà condamné
pour trafic de stupéfiants a fait de la
prison avec michel lelièvre
il est ce soir relâché faute de preuves
dans l'après midi le ministre de la
justice belge est venu à neufchâteau
pour rencontrer le procureur à sa sortie
il se refusera à faire le point sur
l'enquêté
j'ai pas de commentaires a donné c'est
pas moi de donner des commentaires sur
une enquête à une réunion de travail
on a réglé quelques histoires de
matériel personnel et tout ça on a parlé
le ministre et ce soir chez les parents
d'anne marshall disparu en août 95 avec
son ami après avoir été enlevé par marc
dutroux la justice garde toujours espoir
de les retrouver vivantes selon certains
journaux belges elle pourrait être
quelque part en république tchèque dans
un réseau de prostitution
la belgique est l'hommage rendu à julie
et mélissa l'hommage de toute une nation
pour deux de ces enfants martyrisés aux
obsèques à liège ce matin mathieu chez
et maryse échappe
un interminable défilé des camions des
corbillards tous remplis de fleurs
précède les deux cercueils et les
voitures des parents de mélissa et de
julie partie du funérarium
le long cortège prend la route de liège
s'immobilisant un instant devant les
maisons des familles la basilique est
encore loin et déjà la foulée la amassés
le long des routes
immobile en main dans la main et sous
les applaudissements d'un public qui
affiche son soutien
les deux familles pénètre dans la neige
[Musique]
pour les accueillir un prêtre ouvrier
depuis longtemps ils partagent leurs
souffrances et leur colère et toutes les
prières ou sont-elles en ligne et toute
logique on a fait brûler s'asservir quoi
les réunions prière les pèlerinages
est ce que le bon dieu est sourd non ce
n'est pas blasphème que de crier à 6 le
blasphème résidait plutôt dans
l'hypocrisie ou d'or de pieuses
déclaration qui voudraient étouffer les
pourquoi que notre coeur est votée nous
pousse à poser des pourquoi des comment
voilà quatorze mois que les parents en
mal d'explications dénonce les errements
d'une justice impuissante
et si aujourd'hui le reste silencieux
leurs proches sont leurs porte parole
l'acharnement des parents étaient
fondées respectable et exemplaire alors
que les parents avaient contre eux
la culpabilisation la médisance la
suspicion les rumeurs les lettres
obscène le non soutien judiciaire
tous ensemble aujourd'hui disons plus
jamais ça pour qu'à nouveau demain tous
nos enfants sourient et renaîtront
toujours julie et mélissa mais peu à peu
la polémique s'efface reste d'émotion
les enfants du monde entier
qui n'a plus rien à espérer je voudrais
faire une prière à tous les maîtres de
chaque enfant qui disparaît c'est
l'univers du théâtre sur l'espoir vous
l'avenir de pouvoir appartenir
j'ai vu des enfants sont allés les
autres télégramme d'actualité en
commençant par une révélation qui risque
d'affaiblir une justice belge déjà très
controversé la mère de marc dutroux
avait en effet tenté de prévenir les
autorités il y un peu plus d'un an
la lettre dans laquelle elle dénoncé les
agissements de son fils a été
semble-t-il classée sans suite
carole gaessler william irigoyen une
lettre accusatrice dès 1995 la mère du
pédophile marc dutroux dénoncé les
activités de son fils dans une lettre
adressée à la justice belge elle
évoquait notamment des plaintes des
voisins son fils ceux ci se plaignent de
nombreux va-et-vient nocturne concernant
le trafic glock ne est maintenant de
carcasses de voitures mais aussi le
passage de deux jeunes filles entre 16
et 18 ans cette lettre avait été
adressée avant septembre 1995 au parquet
de charleroi mais avait été classée sans
suite par le procureur nous étions pas
une autre époque qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous savons très clairement
qui est monsieur du trou nous étions à
une autre époque j assume cette
responsabilité mais je dis tout de suite
que nous ne l'avons pas fait parce que
toutes les informations devant marc
maury que nous avons eues était négative
dans le même temps c'est une douzième
personne qui a été arrêté aujourd'hui
dans la sphère du réseau pédophile
il s'agit de la compagnie d'un complice
de marc dutroux quand la colère d'un
pays s'exprime dans le plus grand calme
à bruxelles aujourd'hui l'incroyable
mobilisation des populations en mémoire
des enfants victimes du réseau du trou
constitue un véritable défi à la classe
politique le premier ministre ne s'y est
d'ailleurs pas trompé en annonçant une
révision de la constitution
joël françois dumont une marche blanche
qui s'est vite transformée en une
véritable marée humaine comme on n'en
avait pas vu à bruxelles depuis la
libération
aujourd'hui le peuple belge était dans
la rue unis dans une même émotion
plusieurs centaines et milliers de
personnes arborant des fleurs blanches
ou donnant des ballons blancs ont défilé
sous des grands boulevards
un peuple digne et solidaire venus
réclamer haut et fort un renouveau des
institutions on s'est attaqué à des
enfants et à leur beau ici aujourd'hui
on a des fleurs blanches et des ballons
blancs peau sa balise est justement la
piste et l'innocence bafouée en belgique
est ce que vous attendez un changement
particulier les steacks après cette
manifestation c'est quand même ça va
faire changer quelque chose est
actuellement il y a une très forte
différence entre ce que pense le public
est ce que nous divisons pense et je
suis là pour le rappeler qu'il fois pour
regarder pour les parents ce témoignage
extraordinaire est ton ressenti comme un
encouragement pour qu'ils poursuivent
leur combat jusqu'au bout
un message également compris par toute
la classe politique belge
le premier ministre jean luc dehaene ne
s'y est pas trompé en recevant les
parents et les frère et soeur des
victimes dans la salle du conseil des
ministres et leur annoncer son intention
de procéder rapidement à une révision de
la constitution du royaume
tous les papas du monde éprouve à ce
sentiment d'émerveillement de fierté
d'amour pour leurs enfants et nous tous
les adultes
nous avons le devoir de les considérer
en fait autant que tel
je vous remercie beaucoup ivo daalder et
sur l'épisode de cet après-midi la
cavale de quelques heures de marc
dutroux agnès vahramian c'est d'ici que
marc dutroux s'est échappée de ce petit
palais de justice de neufchâteau de sa
fuite
les témoins n'ont entendu que des cris
il était 15 heures j'étais dans le café
et j'ai entendu crier
donc ça devait être les gendarmes et
tout personnel du tribunal
mais on a été voir la vue qui
poursuivait quelqu'un mais on n'a pas vu
la personne comme vendredi dernier jour
où ces images ont été filmées marc
dutroux venait aujourd'hui consulter son
dossier
comme tous les détenus belges il en a le
droit avant chaque comparution en
chambre du conseil
à ce moment là il est seul sans menottes
et avec un unique gendarmes qu'il
bouscule et plaquent au sol puis marc
dutroux s'empare de l'armé du
fonctionnaire qui on l'apprendra plus
tard n'était pas chargée une fois à
l'extérieur
marc dutroux braque alors un
automobiliste qui criait attraper les
attraper le vois de trop et c'est notre
appel interrogé par la presse les
autorités judiciaires ne ferons aucun
commentaire
le procureur de neufchâteau semblait lui
consterné on fera des commentaires après
une fois qu'on aura des informations je
m'excuse mais pendant ce temps là marc
dutroux lui roule vers le luxembourg il
parcourt à une dizaine de kilomètres
jusqu'à saint médard avant d'être repris
dans sa course il est à bord d'une
mégane grise qui ne quittera pas partout
en belgique sur la frontière française
et luxembourgeoise
des barrages sont mis en place les
gendarmes les douanes des trois pays
sont mobilisés cette fuite
l'avocat de marc dutroux tente de
l'expliquer
à mon humble avis marc dutroux a dû
improviser 7
cette décision en l'espace de quelques
secondes et un système de surveillance
on peut le décrié et on peut à nouveau
basculer dans tous les sarcasmes
mais enfin je voudrais dire que ces
hommes de terrain veut expérimenter moi
même à quelques reprises que sont les
trois gendarmes qui l'accompagnait
habituellement faisait tout de même leur
travail de façon à s'insérer trois
heures l'évasion de celui que toute la
belgique tu considères comme l'ennemi
public numéro 1 n'aura pas duré plus
longtemps et à cette heure les barrages
ont été levés les insultes colle à la
peau de marc dutroux
à 46 ans il a le triste privilège d'être
l'homme le plus haï de la belgique un
criminel violeur et tueur
anne et fieux avait 17 et 19 ans julie
et mélissa 8 ans des adolescentes des
enfants victimes du trou et très vite
étiqueté pédophiles mais selon les
experts psychiatres ce n'est pas son
profil
c'est un cas psychiatrique mais quand
même un cas hors norme
je pense que vraiment kalev par la
virulence la violence
symptômes je me sais je pense très
clairement un pervers sadique
c'est pas du tout mes deux fils mais en
gros c'est quelqu'un qui est requise la
haine donc qui place ses recherches
jouissance dans un rapport à l'autre
d'emprise de violence de fascination
selon les psychiatres qui l'ont examiné
marc dutroux rejette sa jeunesse il
grandit à ob près de charleroi
fils d'un couple d'instituteurs aîné de
cinq enfants
l'homme noir si avec beaucoup de
violence le personnage de sa mère à 16
ans il plie bagage
quelqu'un qui a dû se battre très jeune
seul et je répète c'était pas pour ça
que j'ai exclu ces actes et ça explique
certains comportements certains
mécanismes de défense peut-être
aujourd'hui divorcée sa mère est
toujours installé dans le village elle
et son fils se détestent depuis
longtemps bien avant le début de la
faire
vous êtes en contact encore avec votre
fils ou pas non pas du tout depuis
combien d âme
pourquoi madame 1
pour ce que nous en inventant le même
but à terme est à notre sens des retours
et c'est fini plus de contacts vous ne
voulez plus rentrer en contact avec
votre fils vous aimeriez bien madame
d'avoir un fils comme ça je laisse un
fils condamné une première fois en 80 6
à 13 ans de prison pour des enlèvements
des séquestrations et dé viol de cinq
jeunes filles dont des mineures malgré
l'avis défavorable du procureur général
marc dutroux ne purge que la moitié de
sa peine libre le ferrailleur vie des
locations de trafics en tous genres
en prison il s'est marié avec michelle
martin déjà complices de ces premiers
crimes
père de deux enfants il en aura trois
autres avec elle pas de suivi
thérapeutique du trou récidive enlève
violent et cette fois élimine ses
victimes mais à aucun moment il ne
semble éprouver de remords
lui il a trouvé sa solution il être eu
la réponse à sa question existentielle
il connaît son mode de joli sens il s'y
adonne envers et contre tout pour ce
qu'il arrêterait devant les experts marc
dutroux insiste sur son courage sa
philanthropie à l'égard des plus faibles
le criminel n'est pas fou il est
responsable de ses actes le procès de
marc dutroux tant attendu par la
belgique s'est donc ouvert ce matin dans
la petite ville d'arlon sud est du pays
celui qu'on surnomme le monstre de
charleroi risque l'emprisonnement à vie
pour le meurtre de quatre fillettes et
l'enlèvement de deux autres ils se
retrouvent aujourd'hui face à ses juges
aux côtés de trois personnes soupçonnées
d'être ses complices et tout à l'heure
l'homme le plus haï de belgique s'est
assoupi en pleine audience dominique
verdeilhan josé boulesteix des dizaines
de flash reflète sur la vitre du box
blindé
ils sont là tous les quatre ce que la
belgique attend de juger depuis huit ans
mais marc dutroux soigne son image il ne
veut pas être filmés pour nous il ne
sera donc une silhouette une ombre à ses
côtés son épouse michelle martin
son complice de toujours souriant michel
lelièvre et michel nihoul homme qui dans
le box incarne la place du réseau
bouleversé prêt à tout revivre les
parents d'anne et des fieux les deux
dernières victimes avoir été découverte
morte en septembre 96
et le face à face est insupportable car
dans le box marc dutroux est avachi la
tête entre les bras le président de la
cour d'assises le rappel à l'ordre du
trou fait mine de se redresser mais pour
la mère d'anne
l'attitude de l'accusé est insultante
je ne crois pas que c'est une place pour
dormir si on veut dormir il faut aller
dans l'ensemble oui et ça m'énerve
peut-être parce qu'il a mal dormi cette
nuit rongé par le remord
c'est une hypothèse à laquelle je ne
crois pas ou bien plus simplement il a
voulu montrer le mépris qu'ils avaient
pour la justice en général et ses
victimes en particulier à la reprise de
l'audience marc dutroux semble carrément
s'être endormi ceux qui troublent
nullement cette fois la cour et marc
dutroux n'est pas à une provocation près
lors du très brefs interrogatoires de
personnalité il a été le seul à ne pas
se lever pour décliner son identité
c'est donc l'une des images du jour
depuis le début de son procès marc
dutroux refusait de montrer son visage à
la presse
le pédophile a une nouvelle fois pris la
cour d'assises à contre-pied en revenant
sur sa position
autre enseignement de cette journée la
thèse du réseau a été battu en brèche
sur place dominique verdeilhan josé
boulesteix entendre et être vu d'un
simple geste marc dutroux fait
comprendre que dans le box il n'entend
pas les débats au 5e jour l'accusé fait
tomber le masque
il accepte d'être filmé mais c'est sous
la pression des médias s'offusque-t-il
[Musique]
la place publique sans mon autorisation
je n'ai jamais de mon prochain sera
quand j'ai fait avec
aujourd'hui je sais de voir la pression
soit assurée mais ce sont d'autres
images que les jurés ne vont pas quitter
des yeux celle de la cache de la maison
de dutroux sur grand écran des photos
sont projetées marc dutroux avait peint
les murs en jaune pour égayer c'était un
piège difficilement détectables
reconnaît le juge d'instruction jacques
langlois saluée par les uns critiquée
par les autres le juge cherche d'abord à
défendre son travail
j'affirme de manière ferme et définitif
dit il que je n'ai subi aucune pression
de la gendarmerie du pouvoir judiciaire
du pouvoir politique
il n'y a pas de raison d'état dans cette
affaire une mise au point qui divise les
avocats du dossier
oui bon d'accord c'est son opinion c'est
long mais l'union on va nous on est venu
exactement pour démontrer qu'ils à telle
et telle chose dans le dos et on verra
bien
c'est une semaine qui je pense pour le
procès je pense que les gens vont
comprendre exactement ce qui s'est passé
pendant sept ans et
autre ennemi des mieux placés pour le
faire le juge langlois ne cache pas son
intime conviction le personnage central
de la faire dit il c'est marc dutroux
durant cinq ans et demi le magistrat
insiste toutes les pistes ont été
exploitées tous les témoignages ont été
étudiées durant cinq jours le juge
langlois va donc tenter non seulement de
convaincre 12 jurés mais aussi une
opinion publique perplexe je vous lisez
dans les titres nouveau temps fort dans
le procès dutroux un mois après son
ouverture devant les assises d'arlon ce
matin le gendarme michaud a été appelé à
la barre il avait perquisitionné la
maison du trou alors même que julie
ministre s'y trouvaient le gendarme
avait ce jour-là entendu des voix
d'enfants son témoignage devant la
commission parlementaire avait révélé
aux belges les dysfonctionnements entre
gendarmerie justice
hervé ardouin romain rate il a symbolisé
la faillite du système policier belge
ce matin le gendarme michaud se voulait
confiant un patient presque revanchard
je crois que
j'attendais depuis longtemps parce que
au moins ici j'aurai à faire des
professionnels puisque contrairement à
ce qui s'est passé à la commission
parlementaire
24 juin 1995 julie et mélissa
disparaissent à grâce hollogne
très vite l'enquêté piétine mais au même
moment à charleroi
les gendarmes décident d'ouvrir une
enquête parallèle nom de code
othello un suspect marc dutroux tout se
fera désormais dans le plus grand secret
y compris trois perquisitions à
marcinelle à l'époque julie et mélissa
sont séquestrés au sous sol ça laisse
pantois surtout quand on sait qu'il doit
inspecter une maison qui est un
capharnaüm et qu'il n'a même pas une
lampe de poche ce matin à la barre le
gendarme michaud a confirmé avoir
entendu des chuchotements d'enfants lors
d'une de ces perquisitions
mais c'est chuchotis comme il dit
venaient de l'extérieur
quant à la cache il est la conscience
tranquille elle était selon lui un des
slaps c'est d'autant plus perturbant que
si la julie et mélissa en tête elles
vont pas se trouver dans un tiroir d'un
d'un meuble a donc c'est d'autant plus
qu'ils trouvent un spéculum aussi qui
respecte l'homme c'est sûrement je sais
pas c'est quand même bien des éléments
qui sont perturbants et l'assisté percée
et persiste à dire que si ça devait être
commencer et qui passera encore à côté
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'ait pas mis
quelqu'un d'autre alors puisqu'il trouve
rien
lors de sa déposition le gendarme
michaud a également évoqué des
confidences d'anciens détenus selon lui
julie et mélissa aurait été enterré par
marc dutroux et un complice fin novembre
1995 soit 15 jours avant sa première
perquisition
une version qui se lâche peut être sa
conscience mais à laquelle personne ne
semble croire aujourd'hui dans
l'entrebâillement d'une porte sabine 20
ans et demi huit semaines de procès huit
ans après les faits le face-à-face
impossible va enfin avoir lieu
aujourd'hui c'est dur dit elle mais il
fallait que je sois là il ne va pas s'en
sortir comme ça poursuit la jeune fille
c'est impossible
alors sans haine avec retenue sabine
évoque le double visage de dutroux
le protecteur d'abord il m'a dit qu'il
voulait me protéger d'un méchant chef
j'étais assez folle pour le croire le
bourreau ensuite avec une voix d'enfant
elle aborde avec pudeur l'horreur
j'étais la petite boniche sa cendrillon
sa femme quand j'avais fait plaisir à
monsieur je pouvais regarder la
télévision dans la cage dit elle je
m'ennuyais alors un jour du trou est
arrivé avec laeticia voici l'ami que tu
voulais maths il simplement dit à
l'audience
l'atmosphère est suffocante la mère de
laëtitia puis le père d'anne marchal
sont pris de malaise tous deux sont
évacués en ambulance
sabine elle s'est libérée reste le poids
de l'innommable elle aura jusqu'à son
dernier souffle le corps et l'odeur de
dutroux sur le coeur mais je crois
qu'effectivement il a quand même été
ôtés d'un poids et qu'elle a pu dire
tout ce qu'elle avait à dire
pour la première fois marc dutroux fait
profil bas je reconnais mes torts dit il
ses avocats lui avait déconseillé de
demander pardon c'est trop tard
on ne croira pas donc je crois qu'il est
mieux qu'il ne dise rien plutôt que de
demander pardon
dans ce procès fleuve ce face à face
tant attendu n'a duré que 50 minutes
libérateur pour sabine dévastateur pour
du trou depuis l'émission procès
l'accusé tente d'entretenir la thèse du
réseau
ce soir il ne reste plus que la parole
d'une victime son bourreau n'avait qu'un
seul visage celui d'un prédateur isoler
une nouvelle journée éprouvante au
procès dutroux en belgique journées
consacrées encore aux deux seules
victimes survivantes du pédophile
laetitia de l'est a pris la suite de
sabine dardenne avec des échanges
parfois vifs à l'audience sur place
yasmina farber mathieu garden agrippé à
la main de sébastien son petit ami on
est ici à dole et affiche une
décontraction de façade avant de
témoigner
je dirai ce que j'ai à dire voilà
l'épreuve aura duré 45 minutes à la
sortie son âme il embrasse elle n'a pas
flanché
à la barre la jeune femme raconte son
réveil enchaîné un lit les viols de marc
dutroux
il me demandait si ça faisait mal elle
faisait rire dans la maison elle
rencontre sabine il l'appelait fifi huit
ans après leur séjour dans la cave
les deux jeunes femmes se retrouvent
devant la cour d'assises solidaire mais
marc dutroux veut avoir le dernier mot
je leur fais mes plus plates excuses
sabine s'emporte pour être vulgaire il
peut crever avec laeticia est assez
d'accord mais il peut aller se faire
voir aussi un le tort de toute façon il
est trop tard le mal est fait il ne peut
pas revenir en arrière
il ya quand même quatre filles qui sont
décédés et je n'oublierai jamais les
parents des victimes sont venues écouter
ces témoignages comme un devoir de
mémoire
je regarde et issiar dia savez j'ai
l'impression que c'est ma petite fille
qui est là les deux rescapés en les
nerfs solides
surtout quand marc dutroux explique que
sabine l'huissier les côtes pour avoir
de la compagnie
il enchaîne je ne voulais pas que le
réseau lettes u après un certain temps
on finit par s'attacher provocation
excuse même sa défense vacille il ne
comprend pas et ne comprend pas alors
lui il parle que moi je dit de se taire
si marc dutroux reste l'homme le plus
haï de la belgique
laetitia sabine sont bien des héroïnes
comme des saintes qui bénissent des
enfants un signe amical pour montrer
qu'elles sont détendus mais sabine et
laetitia les deux seules victimes
vivantes de marc dutroux savent que
c'est la journée de toutes les pressions
le pédophile et ses complices michel
martin et michel lelièvre sont arrivés
quelques minutes plus tôt ammar sidère
marc dutroux lui s'est dit victime d'un
malaise et exigé un examen médical avant
de descendre dans la cache pour être mis
face à ses responsabilités
il était juste il était bon que dutroux
soit confronté à sa machinerie et il
était juste et il était bon que nous
allions là dans un esprit de pénitence
et de respect à l'égard de celles qui en
ont souffert
mais cette visite et surtout une épreuve
descendre dans la cave de marcinelle
c'est revivre la soutenait il ya les
marques au mur le système de fermeture
les lits superposés dans la chambre de
marc dutroux
là même où les fillettes étaient
enchaînés pour sabine et laetitia tous
vos surgi du passé
on s'attendait pas ça s'attendait pas à
quelque chose d'aussi des dossiers
odieux c'est chez tous ces mortuaire
sais c'est un hand c'est un endroit qui
va nous poursuivre tous et qui a
poursuivi sabine et blondie et elithis
ya dans le cauchemar
ce sont les jurys qui avait demandé
cette visite
marc dutroux lui dans voulais pas me où
il s'est fait excuser pour raisons de
santé et les parties civiles
s'ils sont soulevés 7,1 visiterez c'est
nécessaire certainement ravi pour les
gérer
c'est très important de pouvoir qu'est
ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec les enfants et donc c'est très
simple ce soir laetitia livide a quitté
le palais de justice dans un silence que
personne n'a osé dérange en belgique
c'est la fin d'un marathon judiciaire
comme prévu comme l'avait demandé
l'accusation marc dutroux a été condamné
à la perpétuité la plus sévère des
peines en droit belge satisfaction des
victimes et des familles des victimes
plus réservé en revanche sur les peines
prononcées contre les complices du
pédophile
yasmina farber matthew beard enjazzées
boulesteix quand danemark destros la
réclusion à perpétuité un verdict sans
surprise pour un marc dutroux impassible
la prison à vie un verdict assorti d'un
commentaire du président de la cour
d'assises
je crois que vous vous en sortez quand
même mieux que la plupart de vos
victimes qui ne font du parti du monde
des vivants
ma fille âme qui est morte oui oui en
mémoire elle a été là tous les jours et
je crois qu'il peut être qu'elle veut un
truc très fier
merci
des nerfs qui lâchent après avoir
attendu ce verdict si longtemps michelle
martin l'ex-femme de marc dutroux et
condamné à 30 ans de prison
aucune circonstance atténuante michel
lelièvre l'homme de main toxicomanes
écopent de 25 ans clémence de la cour en
revanche pour michel nihoul cinq ans de
prison pour trafic de drogue
laetitia de l'est étaient convaincus de
l'implication denis houle dans son
enlèvement
c'est une déception je ne suis pas
encore assez contents de ce qu'ils
savaient qui a été dit pour news et ma
foi bon mois
on accepte quand même c'est que le jury
descoings ce verdict du procès du siècle
des anonymes l'aurait voulu plus sévère
je n'excuse que sa belle glace des mots
qui tranche avec la dignité de sabine
dardenne l'une des deux survivantes ou
la résignation de parents pourtant
insatisfait par des réponses judiciaires
que demain il y aura me moque que les
petites ont été enlevés et à l'heure
actuelle c'est toujours la même chose ça
m'a certainement mais on sait toujours
pas qui pour clore ce procès fleuve le
président a tenu à remercier tous les
acteurs et surtout les jurés la belgique
peut être fier de vous at il dit une
belgique qui veut désormais tourner la
page de la sphère du trou sans renier
pour autant un devoir de mémoire pour
les victimes